colonel muammar gaddafi just 32 years
old the ruler of oil-rich Libya Gaddafi
came to power just four years ago when
he deposed the aging King Idris today at
Tripoli Airport he welcomes his friend
president sidebar a of Somalia both are
fanatics but Gaddafi's coup was
bloodless he has no taste for violence
at home he prefers to export the bloody
libation of fanaticism
a street in Belfast another bomb
innocent victims scarred for the rest of
their lives the money that paid for it
probably came from Libya each year the
IRA collects a check for two million
dollars from one of Gaddafi's money
managers in Tripoli round the globe
dozens of scenes like this are being
enacted for the benefit of Gaddafi's
crusade in this issue Eko documents the
man who has turned the gift of vast
wealth to the benefit of evil
tripoli capital of libya once it was a
gay bright city where tourists came to
enjoy the sun sea in the night spots
but today triple-a has lost her smile
beneath the dead cloak of Gaddafi's
Puritan zeal women are back in perda
adulterers are whipped thieves have
their hands amputated Tripoli has lost a
hundred years of progress during the
last four Gaddafi once said the Arab
nation needs someone to make it weep and
not love that he has set himself to do
his instrument is oil and the money it
brings under the Libyan deserts that our
oil reserves of three and a half
thousand million tons already Gaddafi's
regime has three thousand million
dollars in the bank enough to give every
one of Libya's people a better standard
of life but so far Gaddafi has shown
little interest in their needs in
Libya's oil Gaddafi sees a vast
reservoir of personal power power he
hopes one day to make him leader of the
Arab world without oil Libya would be a
backwater with it
Gaddafi can afford to dream of filling
Nasser's empty shoes to stand between
Egypt Sadat and Syria's Assad
only 2% of Libya is cultivated the rest
is desert money could make half the
desert productive Gaddafi prefers to
spend the money on other things instead
he gives his people soldiers guns and
tanks
Gadhafi's oil has fed a vision far
beyond the needs of Libya's two million
people
he shares NASA's dream of a United Arab
world but united under the leadership of
Muammar Gaddafi the first step he saw on
that road was union with Libya's
neighbor Egypt in return for promises of
economic assistance Anwar Sadat signed
an agreement with Gaddafi to merge the
two countries within one year under the
agreement Gaddafi would share as an
equal the presidency of 37 million
people the Arab world was skeptical few
could believe that the Egyptians would
allow themselves to be ruled by a young
hothead from the desert all that Gaddafi
would make good on his pledge of aid
we asked President Gaddafi about these
criticisms it is quite clear that those
who spread such noises such thoughts are
the enemies of our unity and it is
mainly imperialist countries who spread
this sort of room or against unity
that's why between brother Arabic
countries there is no weak and no strong
no wolves to eat the lamb perhaps not
wolves but certainly reluctant allies
Sadat was hesitant to embrace Gaddafi
ISM in July
Gaddafi girded thousands of Libyans to
march on Egypt to pressure Sadat into
cooperation
but Sadat had bigger fish to fry
as Gaddafi's hysterical campaign reached
its height sat at and Syria's Assad were
putting the final touches to their plans
for war with Israel today Gaddafi's
plans have been firmly shelved along
with his promised aid most Egyptians
hope they'll stay there and gather dust
he may have failed for the moment that
is Gaddafi conducting a one-man campaign
for leadership of the Arab world this is
the feeling of others and they have a
right to state their attitudes and
express their feelings as for myself
I do not feel this I feel I am just one
of the soldiers of this nation who has a
duty to fulfill the day and it is quite
enough but Gaddafi has a distorted idea
of duty this man who must remain
anonymous is a former official of the
notorious Black September terrorist
group he risked his life to tell the
cameras how Black September got its
funds we get about eighty eighty-five
million dollar Anil and that is so
Libyan if 30 a irradiance audio if 15 a
Qatar and Abu Dhabi and all the state in
the Persian Gulf
between 10 and 12 and
a Egyptian not psyllium also not and for
other a private source and Algeria
Algeria yes also five minute after the
Munich affair
yes arafat gate from Qaddafi as a price
after the Munich affair a five million
dollar has extra price not as a day
every year again as extra price
$5,000,000 for Yasser Arafat's
contribution to the 1972 Olympic Games
the cold-blooded slaughter of Israeli
athletes Gaddafi rewarded him with five
million dollars last year
terrorists revolutionaries and assassins
in more than 15 countries received a
hundred and eighty million dollars worth
of Libyan oil money to do their grisly
work much of it against governments
friendly to Libya Gaddafi complains that
he is misunderstood to make himself
understood he is turning the Libyan
people's oil into blood